La situation
de l'énergie dans l'Union européenne,
elle n'était pas bonne
puisqu'au début de la crise,
nous importons 64%
de notre énergie de l'extérieur,
notamment l'Allemagne
qui dépendait à 80% du gaz russe.
En fait, il y a une inflation
des prix et une raréfaction de la matière,
donc au niveau de l'énergie, il a fallu au
niveau européen trouver deux solutions
en garantissant l'approvisionnement
en énergie pour tous les Européens
et en travaillant sur les prix
pour que les prix soient
maintenus à un niveau
le plus bas possible.
L'avenir de l'Union européenne
c'est renforcer l'autonomie stratégique énergétique
qui va nous permettre en fait
de moins dépendre des importations.
Donc, dans ce cadre là, il faut développer
tout ce qui peut être produit en Europe,
c'est à dire les énergies renouvelables
qui sont forcément pas délocalisables
puisque l'énergie verte
on va la produire ici,
dans l'Union européenne.
Comme c'est une énergie intermittente,
il faut d'ailleurs des moyens pilotables.
C'est-à-dire que quand
il n'y a pas de soleil ou quand
il n'y a pas de vent,
il faut quand même que l'électricité
soit là pour éclairer
et pour chauffer les gens.
À ce moment là,
il faut du pilotables derrière,
c'est-à-dire d'énergie hydraulique par exemple,
mais également de l'énergie nucléaire
qui est totalement décarbonée.
Comme le but de l'Union européenne,
c'est d'arriver
à la neutralité carbone en 2050,
il faut profiter
de cette crise pour faire des efforts
pour notre environnement
et pour les générations futures.
Nous travaillons sur la directive
RED : Renewable Energy Directive,
la fameuse directive des énergies renouvelables,
qui va nous permettre
d'accélérer l'installation d'éoliennes,
mais également de panneaux photovoltaïques
de nouvelle génération fabriqués
en Europe cette fois-ci, mais également
les énergies marines, énergies osmotiques,
un certain nombre d'énergies moins connues
mais qui sont très neutres pour le climat.
Dans l'Union européenne,
une quinzaine de pays
souhaitent avoir recours à l'énergie
nucléaire en complément des renouvelables.
Donc il faut les aider avec
un cadre européen qui permet d'y arriver.
Et on essaie ensemble
d'avoir une reconnaissance
du nucléaire
à travers la mobilisation de fonds privés,
c'est la taxonomie, à travers la directive
pour les aides d'Etat,
qui va permettre aux États
de financer cette énergie propre
dont on a besoin si on veut atteindre
la décarbonation en 2050.